[Music]
joe
is in topeka kansas hi joe how are you
hey dave and rachel how are you guys
great how can we help
hey so we ran into an issue as of
yesterday
we're on baby steps four five and six we
currently just refinanced our house to a
fifteen year fixed
um turns out we thought a little leak in
our basement we got inspected turns out
that the the whole basement is actually
kind of falling apart on us
it's bowing it has cracks and then
there's black mold on the other side of
the wall
it's uh the project's a lot bigger than
our emergency fund
and we're kind of in that like emotional
stage where you're like i don't want to
make an extreme decision
so i thought this would be my first time
calling you and it's a good one i think
yeah that is a good one okay so what's
your household income
uh we make about eighty thousand a year
is in the emergency fund uh we have ten
thousand
and what is the bid on the wall
uh well i've got two so far one's
eighteen thousand and one
nineteen thousand and i have one more
coming uh this coming week
okay cool all right well um
the bad news is you got a messed up
situation and
uh it's real that that wall that mold
has to go away
and you don't want this wall to fall in
because it's bowing it's got hydrostatic
pressure it's got water on the other
side of it i've been in that situation
many times with properties that we were
rehabbing or owned or bought at
foreclosure
and then you walk in and go oh crap the
basement's about to fall in so
um and the bids you gave me don't sound
ridiculously uh out of line or anything
and they're close to each other which
tells you that nobody's in there trying
to gig you right
so we've got pretty good pretty good
contractors on the scene it sounds like
you've got half the money now and so how
fast can you get nine thousand dollars
together it's not going to fall in
tomorrow
yes sir um i it would probably take a
few months
um just you know standard expenses and
if you just stop
if you stop your 401k temporarily and
you say house is on fire we have a major
mess on the hands
and we need to save four thousand
dollars a month for two months
you could do it yes sir and and really
that's what
we could need yeah and so what you do is
just schedule and schedule your
contractor
that way okay if this is a uh a
two-month
job he can start now
yes sir um i have a quick question we
have about thirty four thousand dollars
in equity in our house
uh would it be worth uh using that
nope no not gonna tell you to borrow
money awesome
never have not gonna start with this
space
yeah no it's uh i didn't know if that
counted as our income or not
as a savings or anything no it's not
savings because you're borrowing money
you're talking about borrowing money on
your equity right
yeah yes i suppose so yes yeah well it
is i mean it's a debt
try not paying it they'll foreclose on
you so you're going into debt so you're
taking a home equity loan or whatever
some kind of second mortgage there to do
this and absolutely not so if it's a
two-month project which it
probably is close to that you can go
ahead and start you've got the you've
got more than half of the money and
you'll have the other half while the
project is underway
and but the contractor doesn't get all
of his money up front and he shouldn't
anyway that's bad business
yes sir okay so you whenever you feel
like you can
stage your cash with the complete you'll
have all the money with the completion
of the job
if you need to wait a month to start it
it's probably okay
i mean it's not your family wasn't dying
of mold yesterday
uh or day before yesterday then
yesterday you found all of it so
i'm not suggesting you live in mold
infested houses for the rest of your
life i'm the
new ramsay's crazy he's lost his ever
loving mind no it's not what i'm saying
but i'm saying that you know a roof that
is leaking
uh you can stop the leak temporarily
until you get the money for the
fix and you know there's this stuff is
most of these things they're like you
said
joe said it well it's emotional yeah
it's oh crap
i was just getting things rolling and
the stupid basement fell in ah
you know and it's emotional it's
disgusting well that's the part of money
that can be frustrating as you're
working a plan
and you're going down and checking off
these baby steps having to go back to
baby step three now
pausing and saving back up the emergency
fund it takes a toll on you i mean it's
not fun it's not fun to go backwards but
that's life and that's why it's here yep
so you'd rather have 10 grand
sitting there in cash that you have to
use versus having no money
so it is but it can be discouraging to
go back but it's worth it it's worth
continuing on
and saying okay we're back a little bit
but we're gonna continue i mean the good
news is it wasn't
forty eight thousand dollars and you
make forty thousand
and you're broke yeah uh right you know
but if it's to a point
this is reachable this is doable yes so
for cars
there's kind of that whole thing okay
i'm driving a beater when do i
upgrade when is the repairs too much to
go into the car right like that whole
discussion
but for a house that's hard no the house
you got to fix it you can't sell it
right
right because the buyer can't the buyer
can't get a permanent mortgage on it if
the basement's falling exactly
so you're fixing this house or you're
going to give it away
you know you're going to sell it for 70
cents on the dollar or something because
you know so at a
40 000 discount for an 18 000 repair or
something like that right
that'll happen too